[Musique]
charlebois terre de vacances de paysages
fabuleux et de sorties chic havre de
villégiature de grand confort qui recèle
un secrets insoupçonnés pour les
touristes de passage
une des particularités de la région de
charlevoix quand qu'on garde la pauvreté
ccim pauvreté qui est invisible
on la voit pauvre renault trudel et
travailleurs saisonniers sont l'emploi
dans une scierie locale lui rapporte
1800 $ par mois pendant quatre mois
l'été des prestations d'assurance-emploi
permettent à ce père de quatre enfants
de toucher 1200 $ par mois pendant
quatre autres mois ça il ya un mois puis
un 4 mois en arrière
c'est là qu'est la capm aucun pas la
région en cours les rabais ces corps
humain ont fait les quatre places qui à
l'extrême les pelleteuses oui mais pour
arriver hier pour que les enfants
mangent comme faux marie ève bélanger et
préposés aux bénéficiaires dans un ch et
celle des de la région depuis deux ans
c'est son salaire qui permet à la
famille de survivre
pour l'instant les deux plus vieux âgées
de 11 10 ans et les jumeaux de 5 ans
vont tous à la même école le primaire
près de la maison ce qui permet de
limiter les frais l'an prochain le plus
vieux ira à l'école secondaire les
dépenses pour le transport et les repas
vont augmenter ce qui me préoccupe c'est
surtout l'avenir des enfants
côté salle à côté de travail
je me dis qu'ils vont partir en dehors
pierres d'après moi ils vont faire le
monde s'ils veulent ça va mieux dans
certains villages de la région de
charlevoix
le taux de chômage et 4 x 5 x jusqu'à 8
fois plus élevés que la moyenne
provinciale
le revenu moyen régional dépasse à peine
le seuil de pauvreté
l'année passée on a cent trente et une
personnes d'un moine de la population
active des taser des gens qui sont des
travailleurs sont qui ont quitté
charlevoix est seulement depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années le nombre de
chômeurs augmente ici alors que la
période de prestations
d'assurance-emploi a été réduite
le taux de pauvreté grep et la vitalité
locales diminuent à vue d'oeil
tant d'années que les gens la population
achète moins mais l'entreprise fait
moins chaud c'est enfin - sous la coupe
dans les employés ou accouplé à 12 mois
de salaire
c'est un peu comme si on était partis
par en arrière
style gaudin est un de ces travailleurs
typique de la région de charlevoix peu
scolarisés sans formation spécialisée
quand l' usine où il travaillait a fermé
ses portes il n'a pas pu retrouver
d'emploi il est devenu un usager
régulier de la banque alimentaire locale
et parce que c'est surprenant quand même
jusqu'à quel point que peuvent lui
rendre service c'est moi j'ai beaucoup
de soutien moral
on a vu dans les dernières années je
voudrais que le visage de la pauvreté au
bourg changé c'est des gens qui
travaillent sont à faible revenu qui ont
plusieurs enfants
ça peut être beaucoup qu'est ce qu'on
voit dernièrement des personnes âgées
qui se retrouve seul puits qui ont une
maison sur les épaules pour capable de
l'avant ccpo vrai que la pauvreté sera
le plus au visage
[Musique]
ici les distances ont beaucoup
d'importance pour avoir un emploi il
faut une voiture ce qui n'est pas à la
portée de tous anne marie leroux aide
les femmes de charlevoix à se trouver un
emploi
pour elle le développement d'un système
de transport public régional devrait
être une priorité même si cela paraît
peu rentables à court terme
je vois ça peut être payant à long terme
aussi parce qu'on bosse enda santé
quelqu'un qui travaille c'est quelqu'un
qui s'accomplit les plus valorisées il
est moins malade il ya toutes les
problématiques peuvent être au lierse
est au bout de la ligne met un scène
investir dans un système de transport je
pensais de quoi qu'ils aient été payant
socialement la région de charlevoix
compte vingt-huit mille habitants
répartis sur six mille kilomètres carrés
c'est une toute petite partie de la
population de la circonscription
électorale qui englobe de nombreuses
banlieues situées à l'est de la ville de
québec
un mélange urbain et rural qui donne la
pression ou résidents de charlevoix que
leur région est oubliée au profit des
secteurs plus densément peuplées ce qui
est important c'est que les partis
politiques présents pendant la campagne
soit à l'écouté des besoins territoriaux
et soual écoute de tout ce qui peut
contribuer à améliorer l'accueil la
qualité de vie des gens
[Musique]
non non non c'est deux ans de plus en
visite à alger présidé côté politique
personne qui n'interpelle dit qu'il y
avait plus de batterie mon très peureux
au lieu de ne pas voter du tout n'est
pas finalisé à quoi au juste
le musée on va les écouter encore comme
pro la campagne pas fini et qu'on va
voir lequel pourrait réellement faire
une différence je le souhaite je le
souhaite